explosive claim blanketing Britain's  front pages today a very young girl and  allegedly been abused by the Queen's  Second Son you're embarrassment sir the  reaction was absolute horror how could  someone like prince Andrew have gotten  into such horrible Behavior it was a  lifetime in the making and has always  known that he had the Queen's intense  affection he is her favorite that's  given him a lot of Leverage people just  love prince Andrew prince Andrew thought  he was more than Royal he thought he was  a celebrity the talk of the dinner  parties was he couldn't keep his  trousers closed when you are the Queen's  son no one ever tells you the truth the  Privacy that Epstein offered that for  Andrew was Heaven Virginia was made to  be a sexual slave of Jeffrey Epstein and  Maxwell the queen took the decision to  fire him this entire sorry Saga boils  down to sex and greed